this is a tiny home on airbnb so far
this year this listing has brought in
over twenty thousand dollars for its
host the typical us host in 2021 earned
over thirteen thousand eight hundred
dollars according to the company the
tiny home doesn't cost a lot to build
and yet it could charge hundreds of
dollars a night airbnb posted a profit
in its second quarter as guests booked a
record number of stays and experiences
and hosts increased prices for rentals
amid high inflation but people didn't
book as much as analysts had projected
and the company's summer bookings
forecast fell short of expectations
obviously it's an incredibly dynamic
period of time but i'm still expecting
an incredibly strong period of travel
even if people pull back spending some
so how did the largest home sharing
platform in the u.s navigate its biggest
crises and could it borrow those lessons
to weather fears of a recession this is
the economics of airbnb
airbnb started around the time of the
2008 financial crisis this was a time
when people were really hard hit by the
recession and they were looking for a
way to make an extra buck in 2016 the
company launched airbnb experiences
which let travelers book classes tours
and outings airbnb also spent more as it
grew the ceo branched out into all kinds
of things like he wanted to have a media
studios he wanted to branch into
transportation and then the pandemic hit
business was down 80 percent forcing
airbnb to take on two billion dollars in
debt and pause all non-essential
projects i hope i never do a side
project again in my life i learned a
lesson i think the lesson is when you
try to do new things aside things they
don't work summer of 2020 was a turning
point for airbnb people started
quarantining with their families friends
started taking staycations while they
could work remote
so that's something that definitely
benefited airbnb local travel became its
stronghold and people started using the
platform for longer stays the company
was one of the hottest public listings
of 2020 though its stock price has
fallen since then amid a broad market
cool off in august airbnb projected
record third quarter revenue on the back
of higher rental prices and said it
expects to post its first full year
profit this year
a lot of businesses have lucky moments
but there's something to be said about
getting lucky and also being able to
ride that wave and capitalize on it
that's what airbnb says it has done from
the start back then in 2008 a lot of
people turned to hosting because they
were losing their homes high housing
prices and a lot of people because they
didn't have as much money were looking
for more affordable ways to travel than
ever before that really helped them
bring a lot of people who were looking
for ways to make up for lost income onto
the platform and you can really see them
capitalize on timing during the pandemic
as well
airbnb redesigned its app and website to
focus on local stays during the pandemic
last summer it launched a flexible
search feature which curates trips for
people who don't know where they want to
go the pandemic and remote work gave us
that flexibility you know we could
travel during the week and still work
remote so airbnb starts noticing this
trend and it says oh my god we can
you know we can sort of capitalize on
this and they do in may airbnb launched
another redesign of its search tool that
split homes into more than 50 categories
as a way to steer people to places they
wouldn't otherwise have picked so what
they're trying to do is they're trying
to fill existing homes instead of adding
more and more homes some analysts say
this is key to the company's future
growth since global occupancy rates are
low
when it comes to addressing safety
issues on its platform some cities have
complained that airbnb has been too
hands-off they're not actively
monitoring these properties because
frankly they can't they don't own them
so that's really where a lot of their
problems stem from four people killed
another for hurt all of it happening in
a house rented out on airbnb after a
2019 halloween shooting the company
announced safety measures including a 24
7 neighborhood hotline to field
complaints
we've banned all parties globally on
airbnb we have a risky reservation queue
where we look at any suspicious activity
and we have a pretty hands-on team
that's using some pretty advanced like
machine learning technology to
essentially identify anything we think
is suspicious if it is we'll continue to
seek more information the company says
the number of party complaints have
dropped 44 percent in the last two years
airbnb has also been trying to reduce
that rate further by doing things like
blocking one or two night stays on new
year's eve and halloween for guests
without a history of positive reviews
but incidents keep happening earlier
this year we had a shooting in
pittsburgh and again you know people
were injured
city officials have also blamed airbnb
for ruining the long-term rental market
in some small communities what's
happened is a lot of people are just
snapping up properties and renting them
and as a result locals don't have enough
properties to rent long term airbnb
doesn't think that it's actually
affected the long-term rental market but
you know if you ask a
city officials they have a different
story for example in 2020 the mayor of
sedona arizona a tourist hotspot said
that the demand for airbnb rentals
worsened the shortage of affordable
housing and demolished the long-term
rental market if we are you know part of
the problem we are going to work with
cities we that's why we've done numerous
agreements of cities to create
restrictions we actually do want airbnb
to get more and more into long-term
housing we want people to really feel
invested in the community one of the
things that airbnb is doing
now is it's trying to
direct people to areas where it has
supply and that sort of also takes the
load off of certain places that that
everyone might go to and that might get
sort of overburdened
in april airbnb announced that its
employees can work from almost anywhere
without a pay cut so if more businesses
do follow airbnb's lead
airbnb stands to gain in its home rental
business because that would mean more
digital nomads more people traveling and
likely booking more airbnbs but some
travelers are concerned about rising
nightly rates and some analysts believe
that hotel chains and competitors like
expedia group stand to gain as business
travel picks up this year so the
question is can airbnb keep up the
momentum
we're an incredibly lean company we've
already been preparing for a storm that
we thought was inevitable for years to
come airbnb dramatically cut costs
during the pandemic and analysts have
credited the company for keeping those
down even as travel rebounded while a
potential economic downturn could
decrease demand airbnb says it could
also bring more hosts to the platform as
the economy is going to be slowing down
i think more and more people are going
to be interested in saving money and i
think they're also going to be
interested in new ways to make money and
unlike hotels with fixed properties
airbnb can adapt quickly by spotlighting
properties that serve travelers changing
needs like it did during the switch to
local travel i think even as we're
entering a recession people been kind of
isolated for years and they're yearning
to get out and the one thing i think
you're gonna see them spend money on is
they're gonna continue to travel
[Music]